[Music]
well where are you going you just said
stick to the plan I am I'm just gonna go
get some chocolate pudding
I'm telling you lunch lady Phyllis
hoards that [ __ ] you realize we have
like tremendous pressure from all sorts
of organizations to not tell you
anything so like anything we reveal to
you will be used against us
[Music]
what are we most excited about I do love
the way the characters have progressed
in the year that you don't see them so
they start out a year later and they're
totally sort of new people as a result
of this experience that happened last
year
Wow you've updated a little bit this is
your perfect choice is Roy's thousand
pounds it's a perfect choice doesn't
have to change
you saw a lot of interesting stuff I
thought last year around the complicated
dynamics between hopper and Joyce but in
a very specific situation like will was
lost and she was like struggling with
that and Hopper was trying to find them
so you have these little dynamics but
now the world is a little more open and
you introduce you know the color of this
Sean's character is like adds a whole
nother level to the world and it really
opens it up and makes it so colourful
Bob doesn't know anything that happened
so he just loves Joyce and fairly things
aren't the same that was always a big
question what would she how does she
talk to the kids about everything that
happened because well kids are who the
kids are and they are there's their
little grown-ups trapped inside
adventures kids bodies
when you're writing for characters that
are in their 40s you know it's they
still have these hearts that are
yearning for the same thing that child
you're in for which is friendship or
which is love or which is acceptance and
so in that way it's a keep reveal that I
yearned for acceptance of love I love
you I accept
hey everybody so they're dropping all
kinds of stranger things season 2 it's
dropping at the end of the month if you
didn't catch that title card at the end
of the promo so if you didn't know I
will be doing videos when the season
gets here so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
and I might do a giveaway too I'll
explain all that stuff at the end of the
video but as they say this picks up a
year later as you can see and I think I
had said in my last big trailer video
that posted around comic-con the events
of season to coincide with Halloween so
it just makes for a lot of fun that they
get to have with that there's a lot of
80s horror pop-culture things that they
reference during the series so that was
the big reason they used the thriller
song in the last video big Michael
Jackson 80s song but was also tied to a
lot of the undead rising up so that sort
of went into the idea of how the upside
down is turning right-side up as in its
coming into the real world like they've
been releasing a lot of posters where
you see something came back with will if
they're just making it sound like the
these'll hydra's they sort of name it at
the end of season 1 is going to be using
will as a conduit to make it into the
real world and then it will sort of
spread the upside down so the real world
will become upside down but as you can
see there's a lot of new characters that
are debuting we have Sean Astin's
character who's gonna be in a
relationship with Will's mother and he
sort of runs the grocery store he's not
meant to be a really crazy character he
just meant to be this normal guy who
gets tied up in all this craziness as
things start to spiral out of control
but obviously part of the other appeal
of casting him is because he was one of
the Goonies in the series is sort of the
modern-day version of that in TV form
but there's a really cool theory about
the Hawkins laboratory with another
character so xi is the big character of
season one you learn they're
experimenting on her but she's number 11
so what happened to the other 10 where
there's another new character called
Roman that they just cast and the theory
is that she's actually going to be
number 10 or she'll be one of the other
10 that escaped from the lab so looking
at the episode titles there are a whole
bunch of 80s Easter eggs in here that
you'll recognize some are a little bit
more subtle
there's episode 1 Mad Max then the boy
who came back to life the pumpkin patch
the palace the storm the Polliwog the
secret cabin the brain in the lost
brother
so the finale is called the lost brother
so the theory is is that they're going
to find somebody else who is lost in the
upside down who was part of the Hawkins
laboratory and they just thought was
gone so you hear the synopsis for this
Roman character and it just sounds like
it will wind up being her lost brother
because it says after growing up
homeless with a drug-addicted mother she
suffered a great loss at an early age
and has been seeking revenge ever since
Roman is ultimately an outsider who
doesn't understand how to connect with
people an emotionally damaged magnetic
young woman who suffered a great loss as
a child although she doesn't live in
Hawkins
she's mysteriously connected to the
supernatural events at the lab so that
just makes it sound like she was one of
the test subjects along with her brother
and she escaped but he did not and was
lost in the upside down so it seems like
she winds up in Hawkins seeking revenge
and she'll have a special connection
with 11and with the other kids the other
real big one who doesn't appear in any
of these promos is actually Paul
Reiser's character he's playing doctor
Owens he's sort of the replacement
person for the Hawkins laboratory
because it was implied that Brenner was
taken by the monster at the end of
season one we don't know if he's alive
but I think they said he'd be coming
back but in a roundabout way like there
was gonna be some big twist for it
so just let me know in the comments what
are you guys most excited for in season
two obviously I think we're expecting
Elevens powers to grow a little bit so
she'll do some crazy [ __ ] there'll be a
crazy number of Easter eggs that's
probably what most of my videos will be
for like I'll try to find all the Easter
eggs in the episodes but if you're big
fan of the hopper character they did say
that we would learn more about his
backstory remember he lost his daughter
so he's sort of emotionally adopted 11
so he'll be really happy when she comes
back but we'll actually get to see a
little bit about what happened without
over explaining it so I almost forgot
they actually also confirm that they
will likely go beyond four seasons so if
you're confused why they would say
something like that the kids are growing
really fast
in fact bin wolfhard was in it he's
gonna grow a couple feet in the next
couple years but their characters aren't
going to age that fast unless they have
some way of explaining that so because
they only shoot like ten to thirteen
episodes of season I think it's just a
little bit easier for them to schedule
around all these other child actors
schedules because Netflix has deep
pockets but it's just really hard to get
an actor when they're busy shooting 150
million dollar movies all year long but
if you were wondering yes there is a
future for stranger things they'll go
four or five seasons as many as they can
so it's not like they're gonna cancel at
anytime soon it was one of those series
that was kind of a slow burn and it took
a lot of people a little while to find
it but also don't forget that the
Punisher is also dropping in November
although there are rumors that it might
drop in October around New York Comic
Con - if that winds up happening then
I'll just start posting episode videos
when it does drop but as we get more
information about that I'll just post
new videos so there'll be more stranger
things as we get closer to the end of
the month obviously all the DC TV stuff
is coming back - so make sure you click
that Bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss any of the videos but you can click
here to re-watch that season 2 trailer
and you can click here for brand new
Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight